we can the NBC family and here at CNBC
we want to give our view is the chance
to learn more about finance hoping you
understand where exactly your money is
going well joining us now in the studio
is Sal Khan founder and executive
director become Academy he's also the
minds behind dozens of videos featured
on CNBC com and help explain financial
concepts and what exactly you're doing
what's your initiative yeah so Khan
Academy itself it's really just started
me with me trying to tutor cousins and I
put my videos on YouTube and they they
got popular and so I quit my old job and
I started doing videos on algebra and
calculus and all the rest and I even do
in a few on economics and finance and so
CNBC contact me said hey we want you to
do more of that and explain what is it
credit default swap or what is the
difference between preferred equity and
regular equity and what is the
difference what is the net present value
of some food anecdotally that you got to
let us from bankers who said that you
saved them from getting fine so they can
learn more about yeah that happened
again last week I was at a building it
is not very confidence building but at
least they had that no I had someone who
has worked in mortgage-backed securities
using that the people out there who
people think they they know they think
they're supposed to know these things
and most people really don't there's so
much out and what I say is the more
jargon someone using so less likely they
actually know the underpinnings of what
and so yeah I mean and you know I think
there a lot of people and say the
mortgage-backed security industry or
signing the documents getting them
stamped by the rating agency and no 10
years old you know I knew what was going
on in the big picture last week you were
talking about how does the need for more
understanding and education about ATF's
how much interest you see in educating
people educating themselves about ETFs
about everybody T is one of them I did
do a video on that but it's one of the
things a lot of people say oh is this
thing I can buy the tracks sorry I
understand what when how does it work
was it a mutual fund is it closed end is
it open n is it something in between and
so that's that's what I try to do is
just to break it down draw it out and
then explain your site is ad-free it is
ad-free we're not for profit and so we
get you know the Gates Foundation Google
have funded us and so yeah kids can
learn algebra without ads any economics
of a cupcake directory and the ekadashi
actually one of your video yes where we
go to predatory pricing and how do you
somebody come say I want to open up a
cupcake factory but I have no idea what
the economics of said factory would be
and therefore you make a video how do
you what the how do you disagree you
know some of those things like the
cupcake factory my old job as an analyst
at a hedge fund I had another company in
mind but I just changed their industry
when I talked about predatory prices and
cupcakes because it seemed much more
benign mysterious very Missouri
mysterious thank you for coming on Sal
yeah thanks for having khanacademy.org
you have some crazy classes on here yes
I never a theist yeah very cool
photosynthesis emphasis we know my deck
is there any sunlight it's kind of like
my plans to watch it so thank you very
much appreciate you coming in all right
learning lots in' Rockefeller Plaza has
been transformed for the summit and
that's where we find Michelle caruso
cabrera along with two leading
innovators in their respective fields
taking away Michelle's Susan's and
coolest and most interesting people I've
met in a really long time during the
year at education nation down here at 30
rock NT it took is the founder of
dimension you this is an educational
video game company that he started used
to be a Citigroup and he's rolling out a
lot of exciting things and Saul Khan
joins us as well he's the founder of the
Khan Academy this is an educational
video and not so not video games of
videos and software companies you both
have the same idea which is that you
want to go directly to the customers
you're not selling to schools you're not
selling to parents necessarily right
well actually so we do have a component
Silva schools and it's been proven but
first when we do multiplayer education
writing so imagine halo minus violence
but allowing a kid in Seoul Korea to
play against the kid in New York City
while they're learning math literacy
science history and so we started out
selling to schools we have large portion
years in public schools etc and now
we're going to the consumer side I guess
my thought was and what I mean you're
trying to you really want to get the
kids like it because historically
official video games
that's exactly right and textbooks and
sore workbooks so if you can do video
games and they're like hey that they
really want to play that they want to
play can incentivize them to learn it's
fantastic Wow I'll tell me about the
Khan Academy idea what say we're not
selling we're not for profit so those
are gonna snow okay but not we are our
target is a student so any ageism we
have six year olds we have homeschoolers
we have the opposing supplement and
they're getting to where YouTube or how
would they get in the product it gets
off of youtube khanacademy.org youtube
is just the videos we have most of our
resources on making a software platform
has a little bit of games in there but
so students can practice everything that
they might learn the videos too and it
goes all the way through calculus
doesn't matter if its profit
not-for-profit does it from my
perspective for profit is how you keep
sustainability going I think that
there's a great way to actually make
trend this amount of money while doing
good at the same time and so that's what
you do how is rollout going hi so you're
you are now selling to schools are you
getting schools involved and it's easier
to sell to charter schools and things
like that or they more adaptable as
opposed to public schools that have a
longer kind of purchase cycle yeah well
most of our users are like we have a two
and a half million students among those
are mostly just independently using it
but we have started pilots the Los Altos
School District in Silicon Valley is the
district lied with it their public
school they're not a charter school or
anything like that we are piloting with
some target schools some private school
public and we're just trying to see how
we can use this thing that's
fundamentally for independent learners
but how we can use it in classrooms are
either one of you providing backbone
analytics yes tools to the apps work is
very very important so how long are the
students playing what are they getting
right and wrong but we actually can go
even deeper we can understand if a
student plays primarily by themselves or
whether they play with others are they
social learner or are they an individual
learner and then you know how you can
help by tutoring or whatever else so a
whole bunch of analytics look it's ready
so all is there yeah no that's the model
that we're trying in the classroom
lectures aren't giving and the teachers
aren't giving lectures anymore they're
not creating homework the students all
working at their own pace and the
teacher gets a dashboard and how that's
the students that are stopped so the
teachers now able to do these one-on-one
interventions or get the peers to teach
each other yeah exactly what about
schools that don't have resources is it
can are they less likely to get this
stuff well so from our perspective
that's one of the reasons i went to the
consumer side much like I'm we're doing
a free model you know what the consumer
via shell the soil the kids said it's at
home can get it for free then we
actually make money from
microtransactions somewhat like Zynga
you know cetera so that sort of thing as
we roll that out so it's when you're
very interested how about you saw ya
know it's it's a it's it's uh yeah we do
we sorry yeah weird don't worry about it
should people be hopeful about education
is their agents we've talked so long
about how we've been failing for
industry you're optimistic very here's
the problem problems right now with the
innovation conversation education sits
tyrant we could have had this
conversation 300 years ago yeah what we
have is google ipod ipod i've had all
these sorts of technology to comment we
can get rid of the traditional
distribution structures go directly to
the kids or go directly to the teachers
and build it up some product that they
want to use last word you know same
thing and I just remember questions
about collagen and I think right now
there's a healthy skepticism of why do
you use technology in the classroom and
I think what we're talking about is now
you have a reason to use it and once you
have a good reason it's actually not
that expensive anymore you have a
three-hundred-dollar laptop you can use
it for five years of sixty dollars a
year and cookies and 10 kids to use a
six dollar ticket for a year textbooks
which can be far more expense for more
system guys thank you so much of a
wonderful conversation ever giver Tyler
back to you